so the dictionary definition of a COO is
a sudden change in our form of
government and for 200 years we in
America have been protected from the
prospect of soldiers policing our
streets our civilian streets by two laws
the 1807 insurrection act and the 1879
Posse Comitatus Act and what Bush did is
with a signing statement he disregarded
limitations Congress set on him and made
it possible for him to deploy these
troops on the street now why is this so
disturbing why do i why am i using such
language designed to get people's
attention because I think it really
requires our attention visit these are
three to four thousand warriors they
were the people who maintained crowd
control in Fallujah
they are not answerable to Congress they
are not answerable to the American
people their only boss is the President
of the United States of America he is
the commander-in-chief so I was just
trying to kind of think this through and
I contacted a source of mine major David
antoon and I asked him and these are
questions I asked because I've studied
closing societies and enclosing
societies often the leader the president
will send military especially during an
election to lead or harass or arrest or
worse voters and opposition leaders and
I said you know if the president tells
the members of the first Brigade to
arrest civilians what happens and he
said they have to do it and I said well
if the president tells the first Brigade
to shoot at civilians what happens I
said they have to do it and I said well
if the president you know tells the
first Brigade to arrest Congress what
happens he said they have to do it so
you know is this a worst-case scenario
obviously is there a reason that the
founding generation made it absolutely
clear that we were not to be policed by
military on the streets that were not
answerable to the people yeah there's a
reason because
they understood from their own
experience of George the Third's
mercenaries intimidating the civilian
population how difficult it is to remain
a free people when the leader has his
own army basically so it's it's very
it's a very serious development and and
it's one I think we need to reverse